françois michel lambert bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ce
matin sur rtl france jean frédéric
poisson doit être avec nous normalement
il va peut-être arriver dans quelques
minutes on a un petit problème technique
on n'arrive pas à le joindre pour le
moment mais ça ne devrait pas tarder
alors le porte parole du gouvernement a
donc vanté hier la mise en place d'un
protocole très protecteur pour cette
rentrée des classes un sous le signe du
coc vide selon vous généralement est-ce
que vous avez le sentiment que cette
rentrée pour les élèves pour les parents
elle a été bien préparé
je pense que surtout le ministre de
l'éducation s'est beaucoup plus se
préoccuper de sujets qui ne sont pas de
l'éducation il ya encore peu il parlait
de la dépense que pourraient faire les
français notamment de l'aide scolaire
donner chaque année que le ministre de
l'éducation est toujours en retard d'un
train et moi je suis inquiet notamment
ce qui est démontré dans nombre de pays
l'allemagne pour parler du pays le plus
proche le ch est depuis six mois
l'aération les systèmes de captation de
co2 les systèmes ont pour vérifier que
la saturation de l'air de la pollution
de l'air est le plus bas possible ne
sont toujours pas dans une stratégie
nationale alors je lui seul le blanquet
rats a par ailleurs confirmé qu'il y
aurait 600 mille postes salivaires par
semaine en école primaire mais l'année
scolaire dernière l'état on avait
commandé des dizaines de millions la
plupart sont restés dans leur boîte et
voyez ce que disait c'est en mai dernier
le secrétaire national du syndicat des
personnels de direction
bruno bobier beach
ça va arriver
voilà enfin alors on a un petit souci
technique bruno gollnisch qui expliquait
que finalement il y avait que 10 % 10 %
de ces de ces textes qui ont été
utilisés le reste était était au placard
du coup est ce que cette stratégie des
autotests dans les établissements elle
semble déjà voué à l'échec selon vous
malheureusement je le crains je crains
qu on ait plus d effet d'annonce des
déchets de volume des effets pour
laisser croire que l'on agit
c'est cet état national centralisateur
qui croient que il va régler dans les
dizaines de milliers d'établissements
scolaires tout d'un coup depuis paris il
n'y a pas de confiance il n'y a pas de
d2 capacité à travailler avec les élus
locaux alors que soient les maires par
exemple pour les écoles primaires les
départements pour les
les collèges et les régions pour les
lycées pardon mais il n'y a pas cette
capacité à dire comment vous sur le
terrain vous voulez agir de quoi vous
avez besoin et je vais nous l'état par
exemple en finançant en faisant des
achats groupés vous accompagnez non il y
à une verticalité et cette verticalité
ça a déjà été vu au début de la crise a
été un gros problème pour la france dans
le traitement de la crise heureusement
que des régions des maires des
départements se sont mobilisés pour
sauver des vies au début de la crise et
aujourd'hui on voit que on reste dans
cette verticalité alors que l'essence
même du fonctionnement de de l'école que
soit primaire collège département
pendant lycée c'est le local ce sont les
élus locaux alors françois michel envers
jean frédéric poisson président du parti
via la voix du peuple nous a rejoint
bonjour jean frédéric poisson merci
d'être avec nous ce matin nous évoquions
donc cette rentrée scolaire avec
françois michel lambert qui pour lui il
trouve qu'il ya eu un manque de
concertation avant cette rentrée
généralement est ce que le gouvernement
l'a bien préparé selon vous jean
frédéric poisson cette rentrée scolaire
d'abord salué faut se méfier de lombers
siégé ensemble sur les bandes a sondé
quelques temps les habitants aux
éditeurs
je partage ce qui vient d'être dit par
par mon collègue je pense que le
principal défi qui était posée à ce
gouvernement c'était de faire un peu
différemment de ce qui se fait
habituellement
sous deux rapports le premier rappeur je
prends ça comme des exemples
c'est effectivement le 7 2 chose bizarre
qui le fait une sorte propagande qui va
laisser des élèves seuls face à la
thématique du vaccin avec ce débat qu'on
organise on sait pas très bien comment
dans le but sans doute de faire une
forme de pression collectif sur les
esprits réfractaires en évacuant
parfaitement les parents de ses
préoccupations dans la conception qui
est la nôtre ce sont des parents qui
sont responsables des délégations de
leurs enfants et sur des sujets aussi
graves que cela la santé de leur enfant
n'est pas normal que l'état décide de
présenter d'une certaine manière la la
réflexion et la position des jeunes et
deuxièmement regarder ce qui se passe en
ce moment sur la question des
récupérateurs d'air
beaucoup de communes font l'effort
d'investir dans du matériel qui permet
de remplacer la fuite de purifier pour
faire en sorte que sur le plan sanitaire
les conditions d'exercice dans des
classes soit meilleur
j'ai été maire et je pense que c'est une
chose que je ferais assez volontiers je
n'ai pas entendu mais peut-être que au
parlement on ad'autres d'autres sons de
cloches d'autres d'autres perspectives
n'ai pas entendu que l'état était sur le
point d'aider les communes qui font ces
achats et qui les subventionnent qui les
soutiennent et est donc en laissant les
communes d'une certaine manière face à
leurs responsabilités
l'état se désengage on sait pas la
première fois c'est pas le premier sujet
sont des choses qu'on connaît depuis
longtemps de désengagement de l'état sur
ses responsabilités mais voyez plutôt
que de laisser les parents avec la
communauté éducative abordé de manière
collective cette question de la santé
des enfants
est au contraire
d'aider les communes c'est-à-dire de ne
pas intervenir quand il quand il
faudrait ne pas intervenir et puis là
intervenir là où il faut bel état fait
d'un verre est alors sous l'égide du
nouveau patron c'est à peu près tout le
temps pareil on est habitués puis
dernier point
il ya cette loi sur séparatisme qui
rentre en vigueur à partir de cette
rentrée j'ai fait partie de ceux qui
l'ont qui l'ont combattu qui sont très
inquiets de ce que je considère là
encore comme une mainmise de l'état sur
de liberté donc non je ne considère pas
que cette rentrée se passe sous un signe
particulier qu'ils soient meilleurs je
pense au contraire qu'elle manifeste le
fait que des comment ce gouvernement
demeure ans qui s'est en quelque sorte
que nos mauvaises habitudes qui ont fait
pour l'instant d'ailleurs du noble
française alors jean frédéric poisson
vous évoquez justement à l'instant la
vaccination pour les élèves on va vous
entendre dans un instant sur ce sujet
françois michel lambert mais avant
retour sur cet édito à ce sujet
justement du maire divers droite de
montfermeil un édito qui a fait vivement
réagir le ministre de la santé olivier
ferrand regardez ce que pense xavier
lemoine de la vaccination des jeunes
élèves
au moment où l'on veut dès la rentrée
vacciner massivement des hommes et des
femmes de plus en plus jeunes je ne peux
qu'inciter les parents à qui le
consentement sera demandé de bien
s'intéresser à la porte et que leur
décision aura de manière irréversible
pour l'avenir de leurs enfants alors
olivier ferrand qui a qualifié cet édito
de xavier lemoine de charlatanisme on
entendait les interrogations de jean
frédéric poisson un peu comme celle de
xavier les moines qu'est ce que vous en
pensez françois michel lambert c'est un
vaccin le vaccin est une arme efficace
qu'il faut utiliser pour pour les élèves
où il devrait y avoir un principe de
précaution en lien avec les parents avec
l'accord des parents qu'est ce que vous
en pensez à ce que vous rejoignez jean
frédéric poisson sur cette question moi
je suis d'abord très attaché à respecter
les scientifiques et les scientifiques
et jean frédéric poisson a rappelé
demande à ce que l'on travaille sur la
qualité de l'air dans les classes et
d'ailleurs ce n'est pas que un problème
de kobe dans la qualité de l'air dans
les classes c est là et je dirais dans
tous les espaces tout dans les espaces
familiaux mais là on est dans les
espaces publics là où le politique peut
intervenir la qualité de l'air est
indispensable or vous avez bien vu vous
l'avez bien entendu vous pouvez le
constater chaque parent le verra en
cette rentrée on est très très loin de
ce qui se fait dans les autres pays et
dans cette politique de quoi qu'il en
coûte apparemment ça coûte trop cher de
protéger la santé de nos enfants donc
moi j'aurais bien aimé qu'ils aient un
plan un grand plan d'investissement dans
les purificateurs d'air des classes
d'école qu'il y ait un plan peut-être
même de formation sur ce point parce que
ce qui compte c'est la santé de nos
enfants et là le gouvernement encore une
fois n'est pas au rendez vous une écho
au rendez vous d'une grande comme avec
des tests salivaires mais c'est pas des
tests salivaires dont nous avons
vraiment besoin nous avons besoin de
purificateurs d'air pour que nos enfants
aient la meilleure qualité d'air dans
dans la journée il passe plus de huit
heures dans parfois dans ses écoles dans
leur classe et imaginer le président l'a
public est à marseille par exemple
ces classes qui peuvent être au bord
d'une route au board d'un espace plutôt
polluée eh bien ça sera bon pour le coc
vide mais ce sera aussi bon par rapport
à la pollution qui est sur place depuis
tant d'années mais moi je pense que le
gouvernement n'est pas au rendez vous là
dessus parce que ce que vous dites en
somme c'est que avant de vacciner les
enfants il ya beaucoup de choses à faire
c'est ça
ce que je dis je je je ne vais pas moi
je ne vais pas moi remettre en cause les
décisions des scientifiques je ne sais
pas quel est le vaccin qui est proposée
connaissez ma proximité avec cuba cuba
va annoncer qu'ils allaient vacciner à
partir de 2 ans mais pas avec un renne
message et ce avec des vaccins j'allais
dire à l'ancienne ce que l'on
al'habitude de d'injecter d'inoculer
pour les enfants est ce que on doit se
poser la question sur la rn messager
mais c'est pas moi qui vais apporter la
réponse donc je ne dirai ni oui ni non
je dirais c'est aux scientifiques de
dire s'il faut vacciner les enfants par
contre ce que nous savons et depuis des
années nous les écologistes nous le
disons depuis plus de 30 ans l'air
pollué tu sais 40 à 100 mille personnes
selon les études en france chaque année
dont des enfants et là ça ne coûtait pas
grand chose à l'état pour sauver des
vies et pour permettre finalement à nos
petits d'avoir la meilleure qualité de
vie possible dans l'environnement de
scolaires alors le port du masque lui
sera obligatoire pour les élèves dans
les salles de classe mais pas exigé en
extérieur et s'inquiète la maire de
lille martine aubry regard des
variants delta est extrêmement
contagieux chez les enfants la question
est de savoir si les enfants ne doivent
pas porter le masque en éléments r
pendant les récréations parce que c'est
là que les enfants se touchent jean
frédéric poisson entendait vos doutes
sur le vaccin en tout cas vos
interrogations sur le port du masque
notamment à l'extérieur vous en pensez
quoi
j'ai pu comprendre depuis le début de la
crise sanitaire que le port du masque en
extérieur ne servait pas à grand chose
en tout cas
comment dire c'est ce que c'est ce que
prétend 2-1 s'attendent autorités
sanitaires qui sont plus avisés que moi
sur ces questions je reviens une seconde
si vous le permettez
de la position de xavier lemoine mon ami
d'un moment fermé il ya quelques temps
que fait le maire de montfermeil d'abord
il s'adresse à ses habitants en cas de
son bulletin municipal ski son droit
c'est même assez fréquent que les nerfs
parlent à leurs habitants et les
bulletins municipaux deuxièmement que
dit il il dit aux parents la chose
suivante
plutôt que de faire aveuglément
confiance
à toute une partie de la propagande
scientifique qui est déversée sur les
peuples français en ce moment interrogez
vous sur ce que fera les vaccins comme
disait prends ça michel lambert à
l'instant qui sont des produits un peu
bizarres dont nous n'avons pas la
maîtrise sur l'avenir de vos enfants
alors même que il me semble avoir
compris là encore que le bénéfice d'être
vacciné pour un enfant particulièrement
quand il est en classe primaire
n'était pas si évident que ça et que
rien d'improvisé à devoir effectivement
envisagé de ce produit là soient donnés
pour des enfants produit dont on
comprend qu'il ne protège pas s'ils n'y
a que ça qui n'empêche pas d'attraper le
virus il n'empêche pas la transmettre et
il n'est pas sans effets secondaires
loin de là le maire fait donc son métier
il alerte la population sur des choses
qui me paraissent importantes et c'est
sa liberté et sa responsabilité qu'un
ministre
qui se soit
un jury à maire en exercice est d'abord
pour moi quelque chose d'insupportable
que deuxièmement ce ministre là qu'il
n'a pas fait d'étincelles dans la
gestion de la qu'ils le fassent c'est
doublement insupportable et
troisièmement que cette espèce
d'arrogance et de suffisance qui conduit
le ministre à prendre position ainsi
contre un élu de la république alors
d'une certaine manière c'est la cerise
sur le gâteau
ce que je conteste ça n'est pas la prise
de position des habits de moine moi je
suis comme tous les français au fond
n'étant pas moi-même médecins et
scientifiques même si comment dire j'ai
d'autres manières d'aborder la réalité
j'essaie de comprendre ce qui se passait
franchement gouvernement où il ya de
temps donc le maire a l'air sa
population le gouvernement plutôt que de
taper le nez sur sur nés des mères qui
tous les jours tous les jours et leurs
populations comme ils peuvent ça ferait
mieux de se taire et travailler plutôt
que de prendre la parole pour dire des
inepties paris alors que la vaccination
le voit bien qu'ils suicider détention
autre polémique ces dernières heures les
propos de jean michel blanquer air pour
qu'il appela les allocations de rentrée
1 seraient détournés dans certaines
familles notamment pour acheter des
écrans plats des propos qu'il a précisé
hier et qu'il a néanmoins maintenu
regarder
si à la fin des parents dépensent pour
autre chose que pour l'enfant
l'argent qui a été donnée par la
puissance publique pour l'enfant ce
n'est pas bien c'est évident que ce
n'est pas dans 100% des cas que l'argent
est dépensé pour les enfants ce sont des
dépenses qui augmentent au mois de
septembre
françois michel lambert à ce qu'il ya
une vraie question sur ce sujet sur
l'euro alors désolé pour les spectateurs
le soleil se lève tant mieux mais ça va
être un peu difficile pour
lectra par contre j'ai exprimé ma colère
j'en ai j'en ai ras-le-bol du ministre
de l'éducation qui se mêle de tout et
qui surtout créer des suspicions
permanente montrent les français les uns
contre les autres
l'idée même de la france liberté égalité
fraternité c'est de ne pas chercher à
monter les uns contre les autres de ne
pas stigmatiser de ne pas apprendre d'un
cas particulier laissé entendre que
c'est une généralité de ne pas créer de
jalousie mes enfants ou plus exactement
mon petit fils ne bénéficiera pas de
cette allocation de rentrée parce que
nous avons la chance d'avoir un
confort de vie d'autres en bénéficient
etc etc
moi je ne suis pas là
parce que peut-être une ou deux
personnes dériverait d'en faire une
généralité et c'est l'essence même de
l'éducation en france c'est l'idée même
que
jean jaurès portée que tous nos anciens
avaient dans l'idée d'une éducation
nationale publique et laïque aujourd'hui
le ministre de l'éducation est très loin
de ses valeurs de nos anciens et je le
critique très fortement qui s'occupe
plutôt de la santé de nos enfants et je
reviens au débat précédent qui s'occupe
d'aller chercher des purificateurs d'air
et de les mettre à disposition des
maires dans les communes alors pour
cette rentrée jean frédéric poisson le
gouvernement elle aussi aussi une
campagne d'affichage sur la laïcité vous
en parlais à l'instant françois michel
lambert on voit entre autres un petit
garçon de couleur blanche aux côtés
d'une petite fille de couleur noire tous
deux dans l'eau accrochée à un robot de
piscine on peut lire permettre à sasha
est née ça d'être dans le lendemain
c'est ça la laïcité alors des syndicats
des politiques ont dénoncé un dévoiement
raciste de la laïcité c'est le cas ou au
contraire cette campagne l uni comme l'a
défendu le gouvernement jean frédéric
poisson
non il ya je crois un regardons bien les
titres est révélateur a encore de la
manière d'être de ce pouvoir
regardons bien dix huit affiches en
réalité sur les 8 affichent une seule
concerne la laïcité c'est la dernière
celle qui est en bas à droite qui parle
du respect des croyances toutes les
autres concernent la notion d'égalité ou
l'intégration ou ou dalida ou ou
d'autres choses comme ça de la liberté
moi je peux pas faire reproche aux
ministres éducation d'essayer de
propager des choses qui sont qui font
partie de notre socle de vie commune il
est même plutôt là pour ça mais pas dans
la confusion
pas dans le mélange pas une espèce de
bouillie conceptuel qui n'a aucun sens
alors ce n'est pas encore fait
l'exercice mais des produits de la terre
dans la journée avaient regardé ce qu'il
ya derrière chacune de ses affiches mais
si effectivement on y trouve la même
volonté de propagande qui que celle qui
préside au texte sur le séparatisme que
le parlement a voté il ya quelques
semaines alors je suis très inquiet et
j'ajouterai à ce qu'il vous évoquiez
tout à l'heure sur le
sur ce que disait de ministres bancaire
en quelques vous arrivez à la fin a
malheureusement manqué oui eh bien
écoutez alors voilà je crois que je n'en
aurais tellement à dire que je vais
m'arrêter là je pense que sur cette
question de la rs évidemment qu'iraqiya
bus mais comme partout j'ai envie de
dire s'il me fait ce constat qu'ils
agissent et qui décide de distribuer
cette terre est sous forme de tickets et
pas sous une forme d'argent liquide mais
suffit il suffit que ce gouvernement
parle parle parle est en réalité aligne
des constats sans jamais rien faire
c'est quand même une des marques là
encore de fabrique du gouvernement et de
la présidence macron depuis cinq ans un
grand merci à tous les deux en tout cas
de vous être exprimé ce matin sur rtl
france merci à lou france et je vous
envoie le soleil de marseille eh bien on
vous en remercie un grand merci à merci
à michel lambert riche
idée puisque de la 10ème circonscription
des bouches-du-rhône merci à mr jean
frédéric poisson au président du parti
est innocent